على هذه الجزيره القطط هنا اكثر من السكان
لدرجه انها اصبحت تسمى جزيره القطط فما
السر وراء هذا الكم الهائل والغريب من
القطط
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
هنا جزيره اوشيما اليابانيه الواقعه جنوب
العاصمه طوكيو القطط هنا تشاهدونها في كل
مكان امام المنازل وداخلها وفي الطرقات
والشوارع وبمحاذاه الشاطئ هذه القطط احضرت
للقريه منذ عشرات السنين والهدف منها كانت
تخليص السكان من خطر القوارض والفئران
الذين اعتدوا تربيه ديدان القز ليستخلص
منها خيوط الحريره المستخدمه في صناعه
شباك الصيد الاسماك
السلاله الاولى من القطط نفذت مهمتها وحمه
السكان من خطر الفئران ثم بدات في
التناسلي والانتشار الى ان وصل عددها لنحو
سته اضعاف قاسمي الجزيره من البشر
ولاحقا انتقل شباب هذا المكان للعمل في
الخارج ولم يبقى سوى كبار السن
والمتقاعدين او السياح حتى اصبح سكان هنا
ضيوف لدى القطط
يا سيدي
محبي القطط لاطعامها وقضاء وقت لطيف معها
فالجزيره خاليه من الفنادق او الفعاليات
السياحيه والترفيهيه ومتاجر تسوق فقط
الكثير من القطط
ههه ونصف جول يكون قدس
[موسيقى]
القطط في الجزيره تتغذى على اي طعام يقدمه
لها السكان او السياح من بقايا الاكل او
اسماك السردين المتوفره بكثره في المياه
المحيطه بالجزيره شهره اوشيما دعت السياحه
من عشاق القطط والحيوانات الاليفه الى
التوافق عليها الامر الذي دعى سكان لتقنين
عدد السياح المسموح لهم بالقدوم يوميا الى
الجزيره لعدم ازعاج السكر على حد سواء
[موسيقى]
اصلا هناك
القطط في اليابان حيوانات
وصل الى نحو عشره ملايين قطه في احصاء
رسميين وشراء عام 2018
شاركونا ارائكم هل ترغبون في الزياره
اوشيما مستعمره القطط اليابانيه